When YouTube mogul PewDiePie visited The Late
Show with Stephen Colbert in October 2015,
the host said:
“Um, I want to thank the internet for allowing
their emperor to be here for the evening.”
That obviously was a joke, but if we had to
elect an internet leader, PewDiePie — a.k.a.
Felix Kjellberg — would certainly be in
the running.
The 26-year-old native of Sweden claims almost
50 million subscribers on his YouTube channel
— the most of anyone by miles.
While even your grandparents might have confusedly
heard the name PewDiePie at least once, how
many people really know his story?
Here are the gritty details behind YouTube's
happiest superstar.
A calling card
PewDiePie, who found fame when he started
recording himself playing video games, gave
himself his oft-squealed nickname …
“PewDiePie”
... because of its resemblance to a common
sound effect found in those games.
“It’s like any gamer, I guess.
We all have our nicknames.
I would nick Pewdie, cuz ‘pew’ like the
lasers...pew pew!
Um, and I would yell out “PewDiePie” whenever
I did well in games.
And people would just laugh, and I just went
with it.”
Kjellberg's first YouTube channel, launched
in 2006, was simply called PewDie (without
the pie).
That second syllable means exactly what you
think it means: "Die."
As in, characters in the games die when the
lasers come out.
However, he re-launched in 2010 after losing
his password to the first account.
He added the "Pie" part because, well, he
likes pie … among other edible items.
Lots-o-loot
$7.4 million a year seems like a lot of money
for a college dropout who worked at a hotdog
stand to make cash while playing video games.
In fact, $7.4 million is a lot of money for
anyone to make.
But according to some analysts, it's nowhere
near the salary Kjellberg should be pulling
right now.
Given his massive subscriber base and the
amount of ad revenue that YouTube is pulling
in from its video plays, experts say he's
actually way underpaid.
Even so, Kjellberg rarely speaks about his
financial earnings from the site because he
says that he didn't get into this business
for the money.
“I didn’t know you could be big at...well
I know people who are big at other type of
videos, but there was no one big at gaming,
and I didn’t know you could make money out
of it.
So it was never, like, a career that I just
quit college to pursue.”
However, he was still none too pleased when
YouTube's monetization policy changed, and
he spoke out against the company's decision.
“If you don’t know what happened, basically
YouTube started unmonetizing people’s videos
without any notice.”
Parental approval
Before he made it big online, Kjellberg's
parents weren't so keen on the idea of him
making a living by playing video games.
They were both highly esteemed executives
in Sweden at the time and seemed to hope he'd
follow in their own footsteps by sending him
to Chalmers University of Technology for industrial
economics.
But the corporate lifestyle simply wasn't
for him.
“Shortly after, I quit college, and so I
had to get a job, and I took whatever job
I could get, which was to work in a hotdog
stand.”
But now that he's proven the worth of this
business, his family seems to have come around.
His mother and sister have both made appearances
on his YouTube channel, although his dad still
seems a bit camera shy.
The Bro Army
The term "bro" has all kinds of negative meathead
connotations here in the United States, but
Kjellberg uses it a lot.
“Hey how’s it going bros?”
Some of his followers have begun to live up
to the connotation.
When other YouTubers play a game that PewDiePie
has already covered, the Bro Army sometimes
comes after them in force for "copying" their
virtual leader.
PewDiePie himself responded by posting a video
mocking his own fans and disabling comments
on his own uploads for awhile.
PewDiePhilanthropist
As harsh as the Bros can be and as much flack
as PewDiePie has gotten for making millions,
he and his fans have done a lot of good.
Kjellberg and the Bro Army have already raised
over $630,000 for Save the Children, over
$446,000 for Charity: Water, and tens of thousands
for other organizations.
“Putting all those together, we have reached
over $1 million towards charities.
How frickin’...that is...ah, I can’t...I
can’t…”
PewDiePie's Cutie Pie
Kjellberg's romance with girlfriend Marzia
is a fairy tale for the digital age.
In 2011, the young Italian woman became familiar
with PewDie's work through some friends, and
became taken with him and wrote him a fan
e-mail.
It didn't take long for him to respond and
then fly out to Italy for a real-life date.
Within a year, Marzia moved to Sweden and
started a YouTube channel of her own, called
CutiePieMarzia.
The two bounced back to Italy for awhile before
settling in England with their two pugs, Edgar
and Maya.
Not a bad journey for a video game-playing
hot dog salesman!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and watch more videos like
the one you just saw.
And don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love, too!